the pentagon's hypersonic weapons
programs suffered a setback after a
booster rocket failed to lift off that's
according to reuters the test was
intended to validate aspects of one of
the hypersonic glide vehicles in
development senior pentagon officials
say a separate series of tests wednesday
was successful on navy and army
hypersonic weapon component prototypes
meantime there is a report tonight that
china performed a second hypersonic
weapons test this summer the financial
times is reporting the second launch was
about two weeks after the first pentagon
and u.s intelligence officials were said
to be caught off guard by the advances
by the chinese the u.s does not
currently have missile defense systems
able to track and take down a hypersonic
missile let's talk about this and other
stories with former secretary of state
mike pompeo mr secretary thanks for
being here
great to be how are you doing tonight
brett i'm good sir um you know you
knowing what you know about the chinese
and their development militarily and
what they have been doing how concerned
are you about these hypersonic missile
tests
yeah but this is this is serious
business their capability now looks to
be within a couple of dozen miles of
target for something that travels at
multiples of the speed of sound so this
creates a new threat vector for the
united states we've seen several of
these during the last six to eight years
not the least of which is certainly
their cyber capabilities that you and i
have spoken about before as well
this is serious stuff we need to respond
to it i would add brett the most
important thing we have to keep in mind
is there the intentions of xi jinping
the general secretary himself right he's
talked about the fact that he wants to
have each of us living in a a world that
looks like his marxist leninist war we
can't permit that and this military tool
that he's developing is just one arrow
in the quiver of xi jinping aimed at
coercive action not only against the
united states but against the west
so the white house has evolved in how
it's answering this question gen saki
was asked about the hypersonic weapons
test report the other day and then
another a series of questions about it
today take a listen
we have been consistent in our approach
with china uh we welcome stiff
competition but do we not we don't do
not want that competition to veer into
conflict and that is certainly what we
convey privately as
tiny well missiles
yes we're not going to to comment on the
specific
report but generally speaking we have
made clear our concerns
about the military capabilities that the
prc continues to pursue yes do we have
concerns we do
and then we're going to continue to
speak out
what else could this administration be
doing message wise or otherwise
in result of what's happening
this is a full-on challenge from the
chinese communist party the first thing
one has to do is recognize that this
isn't about stiff competition this is
about an intention of a communist party
that wants to undermine our way of life
through the ice that's the most
important thing you can do brett uh if
you underestimate this so if you just
talk about this as a competition gosh
they had a good day we had a bad day
that's not what xi jinping and the
communist party about we've seen this
with the soviet union before we know how
communism works that's first step second
the obama administration had completely
ignore these hypersonic programs we
began to build out both our capability
and the capacity to defend against them
we did the same thing in cyber they
certainly need to continue those and
then they need to build up coalitions
much like we had built out the quad with
japan and india and australia to begin
to shape how the west was going to
respond to these new set of activities
from the chinese communist party those
are the things that administration can
do you can find friends and partners and
big economies around the world to push
back against china in the way that
president trump and our team did for our
four years in office you were one of the
first people to speak out about at least
the circumstantial evidence pointing to
a lab leak theory in wuhan
and what you were seeing now we have
this new development about gain of
function research and what the nih was
doing or not doing your thoughts about
how that has evolved as well in in
recent weeks
yeah but i was called racist for
contemplating the idea that this virus
might well have come from a virology lab
inside of china
it's now quite likely that in fact that
was the case
uh it's evolved because i think we've
had government leaders including dr
facchi not speak the truth i heard you
play the quote from senator paul a bit
earlier he clearly wasn't telling
everything he knew about american
involvement taxpayer money going to this
virology lecture to work on research
that was juice and viruses and there's a
lot more questions yet to be answered i
don't think we know the full story but
the fact that this might well have come
from that virology lab and the fact that
now goodness two years on brett the
chinese communist party continues to
cover up the fact that they allowed a
virus to travel around the world that
killed four million people around the
world is something that we should not
discount and that the government our
government needs to find tools and
weapons to respond to the chinese
communist party for what they did to the
world this is four million people no
longer on the planet brat because of
what china did so how should they pay
for it how should the u.s push them to
pay for if in fact that's where this
origin came from
so there's lots of tools we could
certainly find ways to do this in the
court system i i've written about
options there there are many where we
could use our private court system to
benefit those people who were harmed and
injured by what the chinese communist
party did
but they too need to be held accountable
the world health organization is not an
organization they should be part of this
administration said nope we're going to
go back into that while they're apart
well what brett while that lab is still
operating there's no indication they've
improved their safety conditions at that
laboratory and i'm confident they're
still working on
highly contagious viruses in laboratory
those are the kinds of costs you can
begin to impose on chinese communist
party they can't be permitted to roam
freely around the world and participate
in international organizations and hold
an olympics in just a just a couple of
months
and and do that when in fact these
people don't care about human life they
took a highly contagious virus that was
pretty darn lethal and put people on
airplanes to milan italy and you can see
the results they continue today here in
the united states of america hundreds of
thousands of dead here and lots of
people out of work
mr secretary i've got to run but i just
want to say personally you know you look
good you've lost a lot of lbs are you
planning for something big
thanks for noticing yes my son's getting
married in the summer of next year brett
okay all right we'll peg it on that
thank you sir for the time hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else